よし、
みんなええと、500k 行こう 500k
おめでとう、年末までに 100 万 それについては
わかりません
が、ええと
、500k チャンネル登録者
、手術からの復帰おめでとうござい
ます。 見たことがあるかもしれ
ません YouTubeには何も投稿していません
が、昨日病院に行ったばかり
です 私は手術を受けていました 私はボーエン病と呼ばれるこの病気に
かかっています それは初期の皮膚がんのようなもので
、彼らは切りました
それほど大きくない大きな塊の
ように出てきた多分
私の胃の大きな皮膚の塊のよう
なものかもしれません。そうそう、とても楽しかったです。
面白いのは
、私が出した最近のビデオが
日本の素晴らしいコンビニエンス ストアのようなものであることを知っているからです。
また、
フォローアップ ビデオも
、メタ謝罪のようなもので、
自分自身を批判するのが好きです。 男の
伝統的な日本の集会を楽しんでいます ience store
はとても面白いです。なぜなら、そのビデオは最近
私の他のすべてのビデオよりも優れ
て
いるからです。なぜなら、ビデオ全体がこれらの人々を風刺することを意図している
よう
に、日本人に向けられたこれらの YouTube ビデオのように作ることを意図しているためです。
彼らが何もしないとき、観客は
日本を称賛
するだけで、彼らがそれをし
ていると彼らが考えている
からではなく、お金のインセンティブがとても良い
からであることがどこでわかるかを見ることができるようになっています。 ノンストップで日本についてポジティブなことを言ったり
、ビデオでクレイジーなビューを得ることができるようにしたり、また
それを風刺したりしようとしていたのですが
、それは面白かった
です。
複数の
チャンネルがそういうことをやっていますが、
面白いのは、私が
サムネイルをそのように見せたとき、ビデオが非常にうまく機能していることを知っているからです。
あなたはそれらのビデオを作ることを知っていますが、立ち寄って500kおめでとうと言い、最終的にそのプラークが現れるのを待って頑張ってください
.100万だと思います.間違っている可能性があり
ます. ゴールド
は、迅速かつ完全な回復のための百万の祈りです。
どうもありがとうござい
ました。ええと
、
私は今、私の胃の中にたくさんの縫い目を持っています。とても
クール
です。あなたはプラークを手に入れます。
よくわからない
けど、長い間500kに到達しようとしてきた
ので、やっとそこにたどり着いて気分がいいです
こんにちはドゴンヘイ、調子はどうですかええと、
シルバーですええと思います私はすでに持っています
シルバー 100K の途中で
、オーストラリアからの挨拶がサブアソンを行うことを知りました YouTube
のサブアソンが何であるかはわかり
ませんが、Dogan さん、日本の練習とエンターテイメントのためにあなたを長年見てき
ました。  500k ありがとうございます
ええと、私は
まだこれをやったとは思いませんねえ、大丈夫、ここ
に行き
ますか、あなたは
ジャズが好きですか、ええと、ジャズは嫌いではありませんが、ええと
、私が特に情熱を傾けているものではありません
500kストリーム
大丈夫
500kおめでとう ハンガリーから
調子はどうだ ショーが順調に進んでいることを願っています
ロキはダブルドーガンが大好き
です ああ、そうそう、このように私
はこれを取り除く必要があります
大丈夫です
ええと
500kおめでとうございます ねえ
ありがとう たくさん見ました YouTube チャンネル
YouTube うーん
[音楽]
ええと
、これを見るたびに、Dogan
はこれを気に入ると思います。
それはバイランからのものだったので、私
は古いネジの古いCRの古い学校の
トリック
に参加していました.YouTubeの何年も前の
ようにビリングだったコミュニティ.これは2002年2003年のよう
でした。
古いねじだましええ私
釘付けになった
ええと ええ こんにちは ダグ
ねえ 調子はどうですか ええと 500 人おめでとうござい
ます
マジック デザイン
シネマ カメラ
ええと、
コーノは
[音楽]
コミュニティの
外国人です
ああ、ええと、スーパー スーパー サブまたは何と呼びますか
トップ チャット ええと、超一般的です
ありがとう、ビル バール はい、あなたは大きな YouTuber です。
アシスタントを雇う すでに
ビジネス パートナーがいる ええと、JP この時点
で約 1 年半一緒に働いており、
ええ、順調に進んでいます。
私たちが処理できる場合は、もう一度手を差し伸べる可能性があります。
ああ、もう 1 つ、
うーん、どうしたのですか、
これを
見てみましょう
トリックのウィーブのようなグループ ing コミュニティ
トリッキング コミュニティのコミュニティには、多くの人
が弱虫
だったということです。なぜなら、格闘技に夢中になると
、そのコミュニティにはかなりの数の人がいて、そのコミュニティにはかなりの数の人
が空手、
日本、アジアにいるからです。 一般的
にかなりの数のかなりの
重複があり、かなりの数の人
が本当に好きだったナルト
ハジメのIPOなどを知っているので、
ええ、面白いです私はしばらくその名前を聞いていません
が、ええ
いい思い出がよみがえる
[音楽]
うーん
外国
人外国人 外国人
人
[音楽]
外国
人外国人
格闘技や
フリースタイルのアクロバットに夢中だったのです
が、
当時はやってる人はあまりいなかったので、
YouTube が登場する前の小さなコミュニティのようなものでした。
YouTubeが人気になったときのように、
これを説明する最善の方法は何ですか?少なくともアジア以外では、格闘技
はそもそもスポーツの主要なスポーツではない
ため、アメリカではご存知のように、
もちろんサッカーではなく野球のようなものです。
野球、
バスケットボール、サッカー、それらは
格闘技よりもはるかに人気がある
ので、格闘技は
そもそも人気があることを知っているわけではありませんが
、格闘技コミュニティの
コミュニティ内には、
トリックトリックスターと呼ばれる人々のコミュニティがありました. トリッカーズ
武道のトリガー
とこれらは
、彼らが武道の
セッションや競技会などの武道のような
ものを好きになる
だろう
人々になるだろう.
テコンドー
や武術などは非常に
アクロバティックで、体操スタイルのアクロバットとは大きく異なります。
アクロバット アクロバティックな動きなので
、バク転のようではなく
、バタフライ ツイストのように
知っているように、またはキックインのあるバク転のようなものを知っているよう
に
、かなりの数
の人が参加していました。 マーシャル アーツ コミュニティは
、
トリッキングやマーシャル アーツの大会に参加
したいと考えています。その後、彼らは
同じような形をした後など
に、マーシャル アーツ トーナメントに参加し、
その後、
すべてのマットがまだマットの上にあるときに同様のことを行います。 地上の
人々は外に出て、
お互いにワンアップをしたいと思ってい
て、バタフライスイスや
バク転などのようなことをしたいと思っていました。
元々はbylang.com momというウェブサイト
があり、
人々が これをやっている自分たちのビデオをアップロードして、
ある日偶然見つけたとき
、これらのビデオのいくつかを見つけて、
ああ、これはとてもクールで、私はそれ
を学びたいと思っていました。 格闘技の
トリックや、これらすべてを学ぶために必要なことについて、私ができる研究でし
た。当時、
基本的にトリックスターである世界中の誰もが
使用していたTrixチュートリアルと呼ばれる単一のオンラインフォーラムのようなものがありました。 当然のことながら、私も
あなたのためにサインアップしました。そのフォーラムにサインアップしまし
たが、その時点で私の
本名はすでに使用されていました。他の誰か
がそのユーザー名を持っていた
ので、私のユーザー名は何
ですか？ 実際には多くの
カポエイラの動きがあります.
ええと、人々は一種のトリックに統合され
ています.
ええと、
私は当時も本当に禅仏教に
夢中でした.ドルジンを知らない人にとっては、ドルジンは禅をもたらした人々のようなものです.
具体的にはそのような
仏教が日本で
広まりましたええと、禅仏教には複数の種類があります
が、彼が広めた種類
はそのうちの1つであり
、曹洞宗と呼ばれ
ています。 トリック
チュートリアル フォーラム
とええと、たくさんの
思い出がよみがえりますが、その時
も私の本名が取られ
ました。
それは
面白い人物
のようだと思ったので、それ以来行き詰まっていることを知っているようなものです
ゼノム プロジェクト
スーパー チャットを
ありがとうございました 500k に感謝します
遅咲きの舌 31 まだそこにはありませんが、まだ
5 か月しか経っていません ねえ
、少なくともあなたは全力を尽くしてい
ます 決してうまくいかないより遅くなった方が
いいということです。 何らかの形であなたにインスピレーションを与えてくれるかもしれません
。Super Chat には多くの意味があります。本当にありがとうございました。
遅くなっても、
絶対に行かないよりはマシ
です。ローガンさん、日本での社会的孤立にどのように対処していますか。
そもそも内向的
逆効果かそうでないかのようなものです
が、それは一種の
ジューン
ですええと、あなたはバージョンを何と言いますか
、それは矛盾
です、それは矛盾です、そうです、私が内向的であると言うのは矛盾のようなものです
ライブストリーミングが好きなとき
今は300人だけど
矛盾し
てるけど私は一人じゃないみたいなパーティー好きじゃない一
人で
くつろいでるみたいな感じでうまくやれる
よ だから私は日本で友達を
作るのに苦労したような
人になったことは一度もありませ
ん.
私が英語を教えていたときのように、または
Apuで働いていたときのように、または
私がYouTuberになった今、私には
何人かのYouTube仲間がいます. ジョーイもカーナーも知ってるだろ
ええと、クリス、あなた
はアルバトンのマットを何人
か知っています。これを始めて以来
、私が出会った30人または40人の本当にクールなYouTubeの人々を知らないよう
です。
そのコミュニティのみんなと交流する時間は何と言いますか、私は
本当に何を言いますか
、もう一度必要性を感じます
私はもともとひどく社交的な
人ではないので
、コミュニティに本当に満足しています
参加できてとても幸運だったし
、普段は飲み
に行ったり、そういうことはあまりしないので、別府などでご存知のように、ええと、
そうです、社会的孤立にあまり対処していません
とにかく、その質問に時間をかけすぎたのかもしれません。ええと
、パーシヴァルのクールさをこれ以上助けることができなくてごめんなさい
。Bloodborne をプレイするために PS4 を購入しよう
としていましたが、あなたは私にそれを買うように言いました。私はそれを購入し
、私は 6 つのトロフィーを獲得しました プラチナから離れて
今
ドガンありがとう オーンこのような良いゲームは真剣に
私の神にそこにいました
私はこの時点で何度も物語を語ってきましたが、
私は中学校の
ようにハードコアゲーマーのようなビデオゲームに本当に興味がありました
当時人気だったすべてのビデオ ゲームの
ように、私は PS2 が好きで、
その前は N64 を持っていました。明らかに
、ゼルダ 64 のようにオカリナ オブ
タイムと
スマッシュ ブラザーズがオリジナルの
すべてのゲームでしたが、
私がプレイした最初のゲームで
、私の人生に大きな影響を与えたのは
オリジナルのファイナルファンタジー VII
でした
より生産的な方法で時間を使っ
てきましたが、人生でプレイしたゲームが 3 つあります。これらのゲームに時間を
費やしたことを後悔していないだけでなく
、それらのゲームをプレイすることで、人生がより充実したものになったと思います。
信じられないほどの方法 私
はそれを何も変更したくありません.
ゲームとこれらの3つのゲームは、
オリジナルのファイナルファンタジーVII
ジェットグラインドラジオです.ドリームキャストのオリジナルで
あり、次にPS4のブラッドボーン.
人生と芸術を知らないようなものをたくさん学び
ます これらのゲーム これらのゲーム あなたは禅仏教のライフスタイルを生きていますか？
座って瞑想
したりとかそういうことで、
ファイナルファンタジーVIIは私の友人の多くにも影響を与え
ました。ええ、最高の詐欺
最高のゲーム
は、ジェットグラインドラジオに真剣に叫びます。ブラッドボーンは、私が何度も始めたゲームです。
ええと、できません
わかったようです ええ、私はそれらのコメントの両方を受け取りましたか
ねえ、これはありますか わかりませんでした ええと
スーパーチャット
ウン
チー rs
ありがとうございます、そうですか、わかりません どうもありがとうございました
ええと、見てみましょう
外国人として日本で家を買うのは難しかったですか はい、それは
実際には悪夢でした それは悪夢でした
私たちは銀行と非常に多くのトラブルを抱えていたので、本当に詳細に入ります
が、それ
は私が外国人であるため、それよりも少ないことはわかりません。
私たちが購入した場所
は土地そのものですが、
私は外国人だということを少し考えました
が、もしあなたが
永住権を持っていたとしても、私は当時それを持っていませんでした.
ええと、それはそれほど大きな問題で
はありません.私にとっては、物事の組み合わせのようなものでし
た. 永住権を持っていない
私はフルタイムの
YouTuberでし
たが、土地自体にいくつかの問題があり
、銀行は、ああ、これは
私たちが大ざっぱにしないように大ざっぱなような
ものでした。
この土地の価値がどうなるかわからない
10年か15
年か何か
で、私たちが
あなたにローンを与えるのは少し難しいですが、それは彼ら
が最初に私たちに言っ
たことではなく、基本的に物事が下り坂になった
ようなものです。
大分からおはようございます 調子はどう
ですか 外国の方、ありがとうございました
[音楽]
外国の
方 お時間がありましたら私の日本語を訂正してください
この
日本語には明らかな誤りはありませんが、あなたの日本語には明らかな誤りはありません
が、
英語から作られた
日本語というよりも、日本語に翻訳された英語のように聞こえます。
最初は日本語で書き直したので、もう一度チャットを入力します。
より自然な言い方は、
ええと、
おそらくそうかもしれません。
ええと、ドルガかもしれませ
ん。
手術から早く回復することを願ってい
ます。フロリダからのご
無事をお祈りしております。
どうもありがとうございまし
た 良いツイートを作ったのは残念
ですが、
まあ、クールでクールなものを見てみましょう。
どうもありがとうございました。問題あり
ません。日本で何年も過ごした後、コメントをありがとうございまし
た。日本語キーボードと
英語キーボードのどちらが好きですか。日本語キーボードは嫌いです。
私はそれを我慢できませんええと
、アメリカのキーボードの英語のキーボードの方がはるかに高速です
が、
その上、私の意見
では、日本語のキーボードには必要のないほど
多くのボタンがあります
英語から日本語
に、またはその逆に変更するような、うーん専用のボタンですが、そのための
キーボードショートカットのようなプログラムを好きにすることができ
、これらすべての
追加ボタンを日本語キーボードに配置
すると、
各ボタンではなく、各ボタンになります。
t 日本語
キーボードのボタンは、アメリカのキーボードよりもはるかに小さい
ので
、日本語のキーボードで入力を開始すると、
これらすべてのボタンを押し始めますが、
実際にはさまざまなことを行います。
実際には文字ではありません。 アメリカのキーボードのように使用するのに慣れている
ので、
ええと
、私は大丈夫だと答えました。フロリダからあなたが元気になることを願っています。
感謝しています。
ハリケーンに襲われなかったことを願っています。
お久しぶり
です お元気ですか ドーゲン あなたが私の
いとこのエヴァンの大学時代のルームメイトだったことが分かったので
、それはクールですねえ、エヴァン 私はその
男が大好きです とてもクールな男
私は彼と本当に
うまくやっていました 彼は素晴らしい男でした わかりました
ジョニと一緒にトラッシュテイストのポッドキャストに出演してくれませんか ジョーイ・
ガーントとコナーはあなたの仕事が大好きです 500 おめでとうござい
ます。  m you
know 超幸せ fo 彼らと私の
娘たちは
少し大きくなり、最近は少し旅行に行けるように
なったので、まだ落ち込んでいるなら、
彼らのポッドキャストに参加したいです 彼らの
ポッドキャストが大好きです 私は
それを見ていました 昨日病院にいました
実は
異国の
オッケー
スモールワールド そうそう
ずいぶん前にジュリーに誘われたんです
けど 娘が産まれた直後じゃなくて娘が産まれた直後みたい
で 本当に出られない時期
でした 家のことはとてもとても
そうそう、うまくいけば、私たちはすぐにそれを実現することができ
ます. 今日は外国のGテスト. 私は漢字がひどいので、
かなり
大喜びしています.
漢字の学習に費やす時間は意味をなさ
なく
なります。それは、
外来語が日本語の
ような日本語のような漢字に取って代わりつつあるからです。
それは
あなたが慣れている
20 30 年前のように漢字を勉強したときは、お金に見合うだけの価値
がありましたが、最近で
は漢字を勉強してから
、日本のテレビ番組のように見に行くようなもの
です。
日本語の単語
を言うのと同じように、彼らはちょうど外来語のように言っている
ので
、人々は実際には言うことさえありません
反時計回りだと思います ええ
ひこもりでごめんなさい でもあなたに何が起こったの
ですか？
これはゆっくりとやってください。いつでもフリーのように
問題が発生します。
オーケー、
ああ、私は今すぐに動けません。
外国人です。
ええと、
これは私のように自分の
ことを気にかけない多くの人々に伝えるのにちょうどいい話かもしれません。
慣れてい
た 長い間健康に気を使っていませんでしたが
、ほくろのように見えました。最初はほくろだったと思います。
お腹にあったのですが
、少しずつ出始めました。
私が気づいたように大きい これは
普通のほくろよりも少し大きいように見えるので、皮膚科医に行ったとき、
これ
は危険だと思いました。これは皮膚癌のようだと思いますか
？ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ いいえ
心配しないで あなたは元気で私
は大丈夫のようでした
あなたがそう言うなら、私はあなたをすべて連れて行き
ます あなたが専門家であることを知っているので、私はしませんでした
本当に考えすぎです
が、それから
どんどん大きくなっていき、1年後に別の皮膚科医に戻りました.
茶色がかったほくろのように、または
あなたが知っている何かのように
赤のようで薄片のようだった私
はこれが普通で、彼らは
おそらく大丈夫
だと思っていましたこの薬の
ように塗れば大丈夫ですそして私は大丈夫でしたそして
それはちょうど成長し続けましたそして私は次のようでした
触れられない アンジェラ 調子はどうだい 立ち止まって
くれてありがとう
真剣に
別の皮膚科医に行ったところ、
彼はまったく同じ
ことを言った.おそらくあなたは大丈夫
だろう. サンプルを採取
して、それが危険かどうかを確認するために研究室に送ってください。
私はそうしようと思いまし
た.
うーん、
それは一種の皮膚がんのようなものです
あなたが知っているほど危険
な皮膚がんではありませんが、それはしばしば
非常に危険な適切な皮膚がんに変化します。
なぜならそれ
は体の他の部分に広がる可能
性があるからです。 これが半分のサイズだったとき
、私たちがずっと前にこのテストを行うことができたなら、本当に素晴らしい
ことですが、今では、2年
ほどの間にはるかに大きくなり
、彼らは
ああのようでした ええ、クリームなどでこれを修正することはできません
が、その領域の皮膚全体を物理的に切り取る必要があるように
、
私は大丈夫だったので、
先日はそうして入院しましたが、
私がこの話をしたかった
理由は、
ええと、
あなたは本当に
あなた自身の最高の擁護者であり、肌の問題を知っ
ているかどうか、またはあなたが考えていることが何であれ、何かを持っている場合のようなもの
だからです. 少し
疑わしい その
上で寝ないでください。
それが実際に危険であるかどうかを最初に把握できるようになったらすぐに対処してください。
なぜなら、病院に行ってたくさんのお金を費やす必要がなかったので、
後悔するよりも安全だ
から
です。 お金と
地下手術を受けて、
腹部の皮膚の一部が
切り取られていましたが、これをもっと早く見つけていた場合でも
、
最初の数年間私を見た医師は誰も
私が持っていたように真剣に受け止めてくれませんでし
た. 強く押し返して、ちょっと
好きじゃない
よ、サンプルを取ってくれませんか？これは
明らかに普通のモグラと
は
違います。申し訳ありませんが、このスパムをブロックさせてください。
私は
私の話を聞いてくれる適切な良い
医者を見つけました.
だから私はこの人が何を言っていると
思う gは日本語をどのように扱うのですか？それ
は標準的な東京方言で
はありません。理解するのは難しくありませんか？そして、
ええと
、日本には2つまたは3つの方言があり、
本当に過ごす必要があると思います.
理解できるようになる前に方言を理解するのに時間がかかります.
そのうちの1つは東北日本のように外国
と呼ばれていると思います.
彼らは本当に強い方言を持っていると思います.
ええと、それはイベントに関する
もので、もう1つは人形です.
これが
100の真実かどうかはわかりませんが
、
映画「ラストサムライ」のように、
トム・クルーズのように、西洋化のよう
に戦おうとしている日本の町と同盟を結んでいることを知っていると私は理解しています。
ええと、私は
これを正しく理解していると思いますが、そうではないかもしれませんが、
渡辺カンが
モデル化されているはずのキャラクターは
、鹿児島にいたこの男であり、
彼ら
がそれであるかどうかはわかりません もともと非常に
異なっていたのか、そうではなかったのか、
意図的に方言を変更
してさらに理解しにくくした
ようですが、
まあ、ラフィのように、どうですか、
とにかく
、あなたが知っているように、あなたが
望んでいた人々の間の戦いの間、長い話を簡単に言えば、どうもありがとうございました
日本のグローバル化
に反対していた人々は大規模な復興を知っていました.
1868年のよう
に、多くの人々が
日本をよりグローバル
な地球環境に押し込もうとしていた側にいました. 彼らが戦っていた他の人々の日本語を
理解できなかったので、多くの問題がありまし
た.
鹿児島のBengは申し訳ありませんが、そのbotをもう一度世話させてください.
ええと、このチャンネルの非表示ユーザー.
理解するのは本当に本当に難しいです
彼らがネイティブアメリカンの言語のように使っていたと私が信じているのと似て
います。あなたの言うことを忘れてしまいます。
敵が理解できないように暗号化されたメッセージを作成
する 明治維新の戦争で同じようなことが起こった
外国
人は暗号話者だった
理解 する の は 難しい こと で
は あり ませ ん .
ええ , ラスト サムライ の
外国 の
外国 人
の キャラクター は 彼 に 基づい て いる はず です .
西郷隆盛の
「ラストサムライ」にリンクしているウィキペディアのページが
好きだから、ラスト
サムライは外国人
の彼に基づいている
と確信している。
あなたは
よく回復しています
ので、私の家がどこにあるのかはわかりませんが、私
はベッドフォードに住んで
います。 儀式
a 定期的に頻繁に書きますか ビデオ
を書くのにどれくらいの時間がかかりますか
素晴らしいコンテンツを
ありがとう 質問を
ありがとう この質問が好きです
私は大学を卒業する前から卒業後すぐに作家になりたいと思ってい
ました.
私が本当に
好きだった日本のバンドのメインシンガーに会うこと
ができて光栄です.
私が日本語を学ぶきっかけとなったのは実際にバンドだった
ので、彼女に会うことは人生を変える
経験の
ようでした.
簡単に言えば、彼女は
私の兄のようでしたか、私の兄弟は
サラリーマンで、
私の妹は私のよう
でした。
人 この翻訳には同意しないかもしれません
が、オフィスで秘書の役割を果たしている人のようなものです.
伝統的に言え
ば、日本のオフィスのオフィスの女性労働者は、
整理したり、整理した
書類を準備したり、ゲストのためにお茶を準備し
たり、 そのような
ものは明らかに今変化しており、
日本はまだ
先が長いことを
知っている. または
、社会での適切な仕事のような伝統的な道ですが、
ええと、私はいつも
人々に影響を与えるようなことをしたい
と思っていました.
あなたは私が誰だかわからないような気がしましたが
、あなたの音楽のために日本語を勉強し始めました.78年後の今、私は日本にい
ます。
幸せで
、手を差し伸べてありがとうと言いたかっただけで、
実際には
かなり長い手紙
のようでしたが、彼らは小さなバンドだった
ので、彼らは私に歌やメッセージを送ってくれました
。
次のコンサートのよう
に、あなたと話したいと思っていたのですが
、待っていたので、彼らに会い
に出かけるという非常にユニークな機会が
ありました。
ええと
、彼女は文字通り
、私の妹や兄弟のように、彼らは
財政的に
言えば、
あなたが知っているような問題を抱えているような立場にはありませんが
、あなたが書いたような手紙を受け取ることも決してないだろうと私に言いました.
だから
私は好きなことをするのです 人々にインスピレーションを与えたいと思っています
人々を感動させたいと思っています 音楽で違いを作りたいと思っています
そして私はそうでした
真剣
に、
ええと、それは私にとても共鳴し、私
は それは私もやりたいことですが
、私には音楽の才能が
ないので、私は何ができる
かという
ことでした.
たぶん私は書くように試してみるべきだ
と思っていました.この時点で私は
ブログに書いていました.この時点で2、3年はわかりません.
「
これにもう少し傾倒して、
昨年の大学の最後の2年間、もう少し真剣に
執筆を行いました。クリエイティブライティングのコースをたくさん受講し、その後
ずっと、ジェットプログラムの
ようなものをしていました。  3年間、
基本的に日中は学校で英語を教えに行って
、それから
日本のアパートに戻って
、アパートで一人のように、
ただ正しく書くだけで
、基本的にそれを3年間行いました。
当時はあまり外出していなかったので しかし
、私は乗馬チョップを開発したと思いたいのですが、
その間に書くことができるようになり
、
実際にYouTube用に作成したスクリプトの
多く、または
あなたが見たかもしれないYouTubeビデオの多くを私は 実際に
は
、私がジェットプログラムに参加していたときの5、6年前の10年ではなく、10年前の
ように書いたので、3つまたは4つの
例は
、私がジェット
プログラムに参加していたときに書いたバタースクリプトのようなものです。
3年か4年後までのビデオ 同じ
こと、
あのスーパーマーケットのビデオは
別のビデオだ ええとオブリビオンというビデオがあるのは
別のビデオだ
ええと、
おそらく10本のビデオがあるかどうかはわかりません もう
思いつかない
頭のてっぺんから外れましたが
、その意味で、私は執筆の
バックグラウンドを持っており、実際
にAmazonで日本語で入手できる短編小説を2つか3つ持ってい
ます。
t 本当にそんなに月を得る
しかし、彼らは
それらを読んだ人々から
大丈夫な反応を得たので、私はYouTuberになりました。
なぜなら、私は書き続ける
ことができたからです。
私は自分の執筆
能力に自信があり、あなたが知っているよう
だったので、書いて
いたより
も.
それ以来、私はそれを実行してきたばかりですが
、質問は
、ビデオのスクリプトを作成するのにどれくらいの時間がかかるかという
ことだったと思います。実際にはビデオに依存しますが、
一般的に言えば
、典型的なビデオの場合は4日4日です 3
分から 4 分の長さのように、
ええと、他の誰かがあなた
は自分が文章を書くの
が得意
だと思いますかと言っていました
. 音楽]
ええと
、その場合は悪い書き込みを認識します
あなたが言及したことの別の例
は、コーヒーと言う方が自然だと知らされたので、意味があります
ええええええと、
彼らは彼らとは少し異なるニュアンスのようなものを持っ
ていますが、やや
そうです
、そしてこれを書くことの主なことは
私の哲学と同じように、
あなたができる唯一の最善のこと
は
、あなたが書いたものを編集することです.
YouTube や Twitter
で
アイデアを思いついたようなものです。おお、それは面白いアイデアです
ね。圧倒的多数
の人は、面白いアイデア
を受け入れてすぐに吐き出します
。Twitter で考えたのと同じです。
またはYouTubeなどで
、共有ボタンを
押すだけです。でも
、少し時間をかけて、
座って
、考えを生み出す言葉について批判的に考えてみてください。
あなたは10回のうち9回、10回の
うち10回、それを
はるかに面白いものに変えること
ができます 必ずしも面白いとは限りませんが、洗練された
興味深い
パケットはいわば、ここに
良い例があります
うーん
、最近私はつぶやきをしました
ええと
、それは何でしたか ドア
私が書いたとおりに読んでもらいたいのですが、
日本の最大の悲劇は、
世界最高のトイレがあり、メキシコ料理がない
ことです。それなら、フェラーリを所有する
意味はありません。
18,000回のリツイートのように、それはRedditのようなものだったと思いますが、それは
私が費やしたのとまったく同じ
です私はそのツイートでまったく同じことをしました
最高のメキシコ料理ではなく、メキシコ料理がありません。
それは残念
なことです。ツイートを読んで知っているだけで、
ほとんどの
人は、彼
がこのアイデアなどを持っていて、書いたことを知っているようなものだと思うでしょう
ダウンしてからパブ 私はそれを
編集したり編集しなかったりするのに3日ほど費やしましたが、それを修正
するのに丸3日を費やしたのではなく、3日か4日ほど
毎日時間を費やしたようでし
た。 あなたが知っているように
、その日は毎日15分で、私は大丈夫だと思っていました。
これは正しい語順です。
もう一度戻ってみると、
日本の最大の悲劇は、
世界最高のトイレとメキシコ料理がないこと
です。最初に書いたのは
日本の最大の悲劇
は、世界最高のトイレ
があるのにメキシコ料理
がなく、少し不格好すぎた
ことです。
日本の最大の悲劇は
、世界最高のトイレがありますが、メキシコ料理がない
ことです。 読めない そんなに
早く舌からはみ出さ
ないので、私はこれを編集する必要がある
と思っ
た. ハ 世界最高のトイレ
だ 日本の最大の悲劇
は世界最高のトイレがあるのにメキシコ
料理が食べられないことだと私は言った そして私はまったく同じ
ことをした それは
あなたが知っているトラックに私は最初に
それがフェラーリであるべきか、それは
スーパーカーであるべきか、それは日産GTRのようであるべきだ
と思っていました。私はさまざまなニュアンスのすべてのように考え
ました。
もっと具体的に
言えばもっと面白いですが、それが日産 GTR だったらもっともっと面白いでしょうか。それは
日本の車だからです。しかし、私はそうだったのです
が、日産 GTR が何と比較されているかを知っている人はそれほど多くありません。
フェラーリは
正しいので
、すべての
単語
と繰り返し、私は特に優れた作家ではないと思います。これは私がやっていることです。
ええと
編集して再編集して再編集して
再編集して再編集して、もう改善
できないと思うまで
少し時間
をかけて練習すれば
、それが私が人々に与えることができる一番のアドバイス
の
ようなものです。
各文のすべての単語を編集して考えます
文の順序について
考えます 語順について考えます 段落の順序について考えます
すべてをもう少し洗練することができます
通常、
どうもありがとうございました とても感謝しています
k550 ええと 480 円 ありがとうございました
そして手を振っている
レモン Super Chat のもう一方の半分は
外国の
アメリカ アメリカ
そうそう、
知らない人のために言うと、私は最近
ここに家を建てました。そして、ペッパーで、
これはブランドン ジャパンです。480
ドル ツリーのようなものです。480 円
本当だから悲しい 彼のインフレ率であろうとなかろうと
、為替レートは
今まさに日本を殺しているようなものだ それはクレイジーだ
今は 1 ドル 145 円だ それは
私が今日早く 250 ドルを円に換算したように正気
では
ない
うーん、
それはちょうど狂っているようです ええと、
為替レート
ええと、ええと、私は別府に住んでいて
、日本で最も温泉が集中
しています。 最近
これについてのコメディービデオを作ろうとし
ましたが
、私たちは家に温泉を入れたので面白いです私はたくさんの
余分なお金を使いましたが、そうではありませんでした.温泉
を設置するのに5000ドルの
余分なドルがかかったと思います. 日本での温泉旅行のような旅行に行くためだけに 2000 ドルとは思えない
くらいお金を使う人がたくさんいることを考えると、法外な金額ではあり
ませ
んでした。
やってよかったけど面白い
1日の終わり
の10回のうち9回
は、お風呂に入る時間がない
からです。ベッドに入る必要があるのは
、娘たちに本を読んでいたか、
夜更かししたからです。 編集とかなんでもいい
けど、家に温泉があって、
ほとんど使った
ことがない
みたいで、最近手術したから入り
たくても入れない。
おなかが縫われて
お風呂も入れないので
ドーガンさん
大阪公演でバイリンガルの子育てについて質問したのですが おすすめ
の本をありがとう
大阪公演をオンラインでもう一度見る方法はありますか 私
はあなたを覚えています.ええと
、ショーに来てくれてありがとう.
スーパーチャットも
ありがとう.うわーどうもありがとう.
あなたがそれを手に入れたかどうかはわかりません
が. 今日もまた子供たちに読んでい
ました。素晴らしい
素晴らしい本で、
残念ながらこれで
大阪ショーをオンラインで再視聴する方法はもうありません.
しばらくの間
、私が別の
プラットフォームで共有したリンクを使用して再視聴できました
が、リンクが唯一のルールでした.
2週間のライブなので、残念
ながらもうライブではありません
が、ショーに来
てくれてありがとう、まだその本を購入していない場合は
、同じ日に本を購入しまし
た。 良い本
とても良い本です
甘い 2 つの反応が待ちきれません 過充電するのが待ちきれません
今年の
冬は無知な観光客 ホリデー シーズン
それは面白いことですが
日本と同じように今はとても円安
です 観光スポットなら
たとえ彼らが観光客に過大請求したとしても 観光客
はそれが日本の通常の価格だと思う
だろう 今は円安だから
クレイジーだ 彼らはただそう思うだろ
う ああ、それは妥当な価格だ
ええと、広告を挿入するのに良い時期だろう.
クリエイターは広告を挿入することでより多くのお金を稼ぎます
ええと、より多くの視聴者が
見ている 試してみ
てください もう少し待つかもしれ
ませ
ん 5 分か 10 分かはわかりません
こんなに楽しいことは初めてです 私はそれを試してみたいと思っています
が、バイリンガルの子供たちについての本の名前は何ですか? 名前
を教えてください。
ええと、ええと、そう
です.100の簡単なレッスンであなたの子供に読むことを教える方法を見てみましょう.
私の理解では、
あなたの子供に読み方を教えるために使用できることは、
ええと、私は子供たちと一緒にそれを使用しており、
あなたの子供が想定されている本の最後に到達するまでに
一瞬で読めるようになるのは、小学校の
小学校 2 年生レベル
です。アメリカではその
レベルの
ようです。本当にクレイジーです。なぜなら、うちの
子供たちは 5 歳になったばかりで、まだ 5 歳になっ
たばかりだからです。
2年生で、ええと小学校を知っています
彼らは
2、3年くらい経った
ようですが、すでにかなりの量を読むことができます.
ええと
、物語の正確な言葉を覚えているかどうか見てみましょう.
ゲート 牛
は言った
ああ、このゲートは暑いです 私は暑いゲートが
好きではありません
私は今行きます またはそのようなもの あなた
は非常に非常に簡単な英語を知っていますが
、米国でさえ、
ほとんどの5歳児
が持っているように、
ええと、そうではありません 読み始める
両親
がホットゲートとは何かに多く
の時間を費やしていない限り、本当に適切に読み始めたことには
なりません。 この本がどれほどうまく機能しているかは注目に値します 本当に素晴らしいです わかりました
外国の YouTuber
[音楽]
YouTube チャンネルのようですね あなたは YouTuber ですか
ええと、
私が 4 歳のとき、チャットでジーザスの高い IQ を読むことができることに気付き
ました
5時過ぎだったので、私の子供たちはすでに元気になっているようです
私が彼らの年齢だったときよりも彼らの年齢で読んでいる
ので、
ええと、私がこれについて話すときはいつもこれを言うように、追加の努力をしなければなりませんが、
ジョーイやガーントのような人々のように、ええと、彼らは知っ
ています 「バイリンガル
です ジョーイは話します
私と違ってあなたは正しくバイリンガルです 私はあなた
がジョーイがどこにいるかのように近くさえ知りません
またはええと 私は明らかにガーンの言語能力について本当に話すことはでき
ません なぜなら私は
タイ語について何も知らないからです でも
彼も完全に
バイリンガルであり、
彼らが話したことは、
両親は必ずしもそれについて非常に厳格ではなかっ
たようだという
ことです 彼らは日本語やタイ語などの 1 つの言語で
、子供たち
が英語のように話そう
としても、親は 2 番目の言語を正しく話すように強制するような反応さえしません。
そしてええと 繰り返しますが、
それは子供の視点から見たものです。いわば、
少し意地悪なことを言っているようなもの
です。あなたが私を理解していることはわかって
います。なぜあなたは反応しないのですか？
あなた
がそれを理解していることを彼らが知ったとき、あなたの子供たちはその第二言語の練習をやめるべきです.
ええと
、彼らが消費するメディアの少なくともかなりの量
は英語のメディア
などです。
たとえあなたがバイリンガルの家庭で育ったとしても、2つの言語を上手に
使えるように
するための追加の努力. ええ、彼らは完全に聞こえ
ますええ、彼らは努力を前面に押し出し、
ネイティブに聞こえるように聞こえますが
、物事を書き始めたときのように
、私はジョーイとガーについて話しているのではありません
私はバイリンガル環境で育った他の人々について話しているのです
しかし、それから追加の努力をしませんでした.
ええと
、彼らの文章を見たときに、第二言語がそれほど得意ではないことがすぐにわかることがよくある
ので、私はあなたのスキットを何年も見てきました.
とてもランダムですが、いつも
面白いコンテンツを
ありがとうございます ありがとう 熱いゲートは好きではありません 今は行きません
ねえ、それは素晴らしいコメントです どうもありがとうございました
mistakon そしてそれから私も
[音楽]
外国人
留学についての私のアドバイス
は、ちょうど私が
話していたのと同じようなものです。とても難しいようですが、
もし日本語を真剣に学び
たいのなら、他の留学生と一緒に出かけないでください。
l 繰り返しますが、あなたは常に追加の努力をしなければなりません
。私たち全員が私と同じ留学プログラムに参加しているすべての人々のように、
彼らは一種の
2つのグループのようなもの
でした。
少し日本に行ったようなもので、彼らは
あなたが知っているように、どこかで1年間海外
に行きたいと思っていました.
日本人で、最初のグループの人たちと同じように、
基本的には
留学バブルの中にとどまり、他の留学生と
一緒に寮に住んでいて、
留学生と
一緒に電車で学校に通ってい
ました。
寮からの彼らの仲間を知っていて、
それは面白かったでしょう.なぜなら私
はそのグループにいたので
、途中でホームステイプログラムの研究に変更しました
が、それは
ただの その環境で再び英語を使うのはとても簡単
です。正しいことをするのは自然なことだからです。私は仕事で
多くの素晴らしい人々に出会い、日本に留学していたときにロジャー・スワンのように多くの
素晴らしい友情を築きました。
ロジャー・スワンは元の j-vlogger の 1 人のようで
、
10 年前に
この時点でおそらく 11 歳で亡くなり
ました。 日本
とええと
、彼はオーディションの
ような日本のホラー映画
やイチ・ザ・キラーなどのレビュー
を書いていました。彼は寮の私の隣に住んでいました。
私は彼と素晴らしい素晴らしい友情を持ってい
ました.彼はとても素晴らしい人
でした.
これらの偉大な f
riends と一緒に暮らし、一緒に
楽しい時間を過ごして
いる 嵐から抜け出さ
なければならないので、ホームステイをする必要があります。
もし私がそうしたら、日本語が上手に
なり、それが私がしたことであり、
そのおかげで私の
日本語は大幅に改善
されたと思いますが、それ
はあなたの
目標次第です。
人によって優先順位が異なる 優先順位が
異なる人もいます あなたからより多くを得る人
もいます 社会的相互作用
を知っています それが留学中の学生との交流
なのか、それとも日本の学生との交流なのか、
私の友達のマット対日本
は
、彼が最初の留学プログラムでホームステイをしてい
たように、この本当に面白い話を持っていますが、
彼はとても熱心に勉強していた
ようで、彼は自分の部屋に滞在したいと思っていました。
ただ外出するのではなく、フラッシュカードを勉強
して、週末に日本を探索
するのと同じように、それはとても面白い
です、あなたはそのような状況を何と言いますか
、そうですマットのマットは信じられないほどの
日本語を持っているので
、私よりも上手ですアンジェラに感謝
します ええと 10 ユーロ 退院できてとても嬉しい
です ええと 50 万ドルのお祝いをするの
を忘れて
いました アンジェラは私の
長い間の 1 人でした 本当に長い間私のファンでした
今のところ、
彼女は私をとても支えてくれていて、Twitch のモデレーターの 1 人でもある
ので、普段
は YouTube でストリーミングしていませ
ん 率直に言うと
、私のコメディ コンテンツが薄められていると思います 多く
の人はそうではないと思います
これを見たいと言いたいのですが、彼らはジョークを見たいと思っていると
思いますが、私はストリーミングを楽しんでいる
ので、Twitchで週に1回程度ストリーミングして
います。アンジェラはそこで大きな助けになりました。アンジェラに
感謝します。 長年にわたるすべてのサポートに
本当に感謝しています テ
大丈夫です ええと、ランドール ランダム ランドール
は
、あなたが
2 階の部屋の天井が低いということは、通常の寝室とは見なされないということを言っているのかもわかりませんが、高すぎて 1.4 メートルではない
ことを詳しく説明していただけますか?
ロフト
はオラスの土地を購入したばかりですええ
[音楽]
とにかくあなたのセキュリティになることができますとにかくキャンペーンですとにかくそれは正しいと思いますそれ
は
高すぎて1.4にはなりませ
ん 高さ
が1.4メートル未満
であるという意味で、規制に何と言いますか
、頭の中で2つのことを混乱させていたので、収納
スペースがそこの天井の高さ1.4メートル未満であるように、それは
それに従っています 部屋としてはカウントされません
が、ええと、ロフトはただの
部屋です。通常の部屋としてカウントされる
と思いますが、実際に
は違います。通常の部屋ではなく、ロフトでもないと思います。まったく別のものだと思います。
でも
それが何だったか思い出せない
b ええと
、彼らはおっと
、天井をかなり低く保つ必要があった何らかの理由がありました
.Twitchリンクを削除してもらえ
ますか.Duganの下にもあると思います. または私の
YouTubeまたはそれが何であれ
[音楽]
これは外国
対日本です 彼が日本にいる
ので、あなたは直接コラボをする
つもりですか しかし、ええ、
最終的に彼に会ったのは本当にクールでした
うーん、
これは
外国人
です この
状況では、サイチュまたはトチュウと言う方が自然かもしれません
とにかく、私のアドバイスは
、土地に多くの時間を費やすことです
ええと、私たちの家にとっては家そのものだと思います
私
たちがここに持っている家に満足することはできなかったように信じられないほどでしたが、私たち
は
モデルハウスに行ってそれにとても感銘を受け、すぐ
に恋に落ちたので、
急いで家に入れました。
私たち
は十分な時間をかけませんでした 私たちが購入した土地を調査しましたが、その
土地に建物を建て始めるまで
、その土地が抱えていたこれらすべての問題について
知りませんでした。
土地を決めていない段階で
長い時間をかけ
て家を建てていくうちに変えていける部分は結構あると思いますが
、土地を買ってしまえば、 それから
抜け出すのは難しいので、それに多くの時間を費やして
ください。
適切な場所に建設していることを確認
してください。水が良好であることを確認してください。
通りが良好であり、すべて
が世話をされているようです 銀行があなたにお金を
くれるかどうかのように、私たちに起こったことなので、私有の道路
やそのようなものではあり
ません。
それが私たちに起こったことです
。
フォーリン
オー ヘイ オーケー ルーイ DC ありがとう v
スーパー チャット ワンピースについては、ええと思います。ルフィだと
思います。知らない人のために、私の
仲間と
私の相棒のマヌ
を見ました。 私の家のように
ビデオを公開 彼の
チャンネル全体が 1 つの作品に捧げ
られているのですが、とても面白いです。
日本の
出版社やアニメ会社と同じように
、彼らは著作権法などについて非常に厳格で
、
彼はチャンネル ストライキのようなものは受け
たくないので、最近まで彼の動画は見たことがありませんでした
が、彼は このビデオを共有して、
なぜワンピースを見なければならないのか
、入院中に見て、ワンピースを
見るべきだと思った
とても良いビデオでしたが、とにかくどうも
ありがとうございました町田に勉強に行きます
海外 3月から 7月ですが、私はとても
社交的ではないので、日本人の友達を作るのが心配です。
具体的なヒントはあります
か? 先ほども話しました
が、私もあまり社交的ではないので
、アドバイスをするのは難しいです.
でも
それは本当に
あなたがどんな友達が欲しいかによると
思います.あなたができる最善のこと
は,あなたが本当に夢中になっ
ているような趣味
を持っているなら,その趣味を持つ日本人の友達を作ってみることです.
そのよう
な大学のような
国際クラブの
ような日本人の友達
を作ろうとするな.
州や他の場所のように
、彼らがそのクラブに
いる理由は、
彼らが英語を
話せる外国人の友達
を見つけたいからですが、ブレイク
ダンスサークルや 壊す  ダンス部
とかなんでも最初から英語
すら話さない可能性が高いので
、留学中にまたやったのですが
、この2つのグループがあり、この2
つが学校に1つのクラブがありました
それは国際
クラブのようなもので、そこにはたくさんの
日本人学生がい
て、彼らは外国人の友達を作りたくて参加していて
、みんな外国人の友達と英語で話していまし
た。私がそのクラブにいたとき、私は
これは私にとってうまくいかないようなものでした。
何か私が利用されているような
もの
だった
ので、新しい友達のグループのようなものを見つけたいと思っ
ていました。  acrobat あなたが知っているアクロバット
スポーツ 私が以前やっていたアクロバット スポーツ 私は何人かの友達を作り
ました。彼らは
また Ko 大学のダンス チームのようなものでした。
彼らはまったく英語を話さなかったので
、
うまくいきました。
あなたもあなたの趣味を共有する人を見つけることができます
オーケーアジアン ボストンは
外国人です
[音楽]
あなた
はヨガだからです
外国
人です
外国人です
[音楽]
想像している
から
です
ウェブ
ストリーマーのポッドキャストでネイティブのスピーチに触れてみてください ええと、
私は実際に日本の現実の映画をお勧めしたいと思います
ええと、先ほどお話しした映画です
ええと、12 人の親切な日本人
私はこれよりも優れた映画を見つけたことがありません。
その理由は次のとおりです。
これは法廷ドラマであり、
すべてが 1 つの部屋で行われ
、日本人が
2 時間話して
いるだけなので、日本語で話していない映画
には意味がありません。
映画の冒頭のように、映画が進行するにつれて、さまざまなレベルの日本語を聞くことができるので、それも
素晴らしい
ことです。 映画
では、部屋にいる人は誰も
お互いを知らないので、お互いにとても
丁寧な日本語を使ってい
ますが、映画が進行し、
登場人物が
お互いに慣れるにつれて、一部の登場人物は
よりリラックスした言葉を使い始めます. 日本語な
ので、さまざまな種類の日本語に触れられる
可能性があります.唯一の潜在的な欠点は、80年代のよう
に出てきたと思うように少し古いことです.
おそらく80年代後半のよう
に. そういう意味では、80 年代と
同じくらい多くの借用語はありません。
良いことだと思いますが、
率直に言って
、映画で使用されている可能性のある言葉が多く
、最近ではあまり使用されていません。 これ
は残念なことだと思いますが、ええと、それは
あなたが日本語を上達させるために使用できる最高の映画だと思います。
このネイティブの露出のため
に、言い換えると
、最初から最後まで日本語のスピーチに他ならない日本映画です。
日本語を学ん
でいる外国人ではなく、あなたが知っている日本人を対象としています 私はそれが
大好きで、それも
素晴らしい映画です 素晴らしい映画だと思うので、
強くお勧めし
ます わかりました ローガン正解 500k韓国語
パッチおめでとうございます 似たようなことをしようとしています
ええと、あなたと似たような仕事をしていますが
、韓国語ですべての
インスピレーションに感謝します 一緒に遊びに来てください ええと 釜山
いつか、ありがとうございました
私はジェットプログラムをやっていて、私が英語を教え始めたときだから
、もし私がそこにいたら本当に感謝して
います。オファーに
感謝します。もちろん、スーパーチャットに感謝します.
ええと、続けましょう. どうしたの犬
と幸せ 500k 私はビデオに反応し、
誰かの日本語情報を
盗みました 私のものを盗み取り、無限
詐欺コンテンツにフィードしたい ループ
ええと、あなたは日本人のネイティブですか、それともあなたは
英語の
ネイティブですか 私はビデオに反応し、
n  itpicked someone's Japanese info
you nitpicked their Japanese は
私のものを盗み、無限のコンテンツにフィードしたい
ループああ、これらのボットを見てください、これらの
ボットは制御不能になって
います。
修正されたと思います
申し訳ありませんが、あなたが何を
言っているのか完全にはわかりませんが、湯田に
反応したように、かなりの数の反応ビデオを作成しました
ジョーイとクリスの日本語に反応するの
はもちろん、ジョーイの日本語のよう
に反応することは不可能です。
文字通り完璧だからです。ほとんどのネイティブの日本語よりも優れてい
ます。また
、クリスの日本語に真剣に反応するのは愚かなことだと思い
ます。 そもそも彼の日本語が素晴らしいことは知っ
ているが、それは
彼の知られていることではないので
、アイデアにとって奇妙だと思うのは奇妙だと知っている.
クリスが
監督のスタイルのようなものであるか、または
これらの本当に
素晴らしいビデオを作成するために彼が本当に知っていること
は何でも、私がやろうとしたのはもちろん、
すべてをコメディにして本当に
何よりも自分をからかうだけで
、ビデオはかなりうまくいったと思います。ええと、私はそう思うのが
好きです。
オーケー、デルガンは何年もあなたを見てきました
。500kおめでとう
ございます。初心者のスラッシュにおすすめのメディアはありますか
中級レベルの日本語
ええと、もう一度入力します。
古い映画
ですが、初級者または中級者が見ることができる最高の映画です。
私が見始めたときのレベルです。
その映画を見ていて
面白かったです。
何回も聞いているうちに
理解できる
ようになり
ました 彼の映画
は私が私であるという点がありまし
たが、それは面白かっ
たです.長い文章のようなものがあり、私が言っている
ことは何も理解できませんでし
たが、映画を何度も見たので、
この2つの単語だけを調べて、これらの単語が
理解できなくても
、
周囲の文の文脈が
理解できるので、文を理解するの
が好きになりました。同じことを
繰り返し見て、 理解力を高めようとしていて、日本語の音をよく理解しようとしている場合は、もう一度やり直してください。
個人的に
は、日本語を勉強していると自分に言い聞かせることと、アニメのようにすることには違いがあると思うからです。
どんちゃん騒ぎと、すべてのエピソードで
さまざまなことが起こっていることを知っている
ようなものかもしれませんが、そうではないかもしれませんが
、繰り返される言葉はそれほど多くあり
ません。 短期
記憶に入ってから、いわばもう一方の耳にまっすぐに出
ますが、
同じことを何度も何度も見ると、
それらがあなたの骨
に染み込んでしまうので、私は非常に非常に
非常に高くなります 12 人の親切な日本人を繰り返し見ることをお勧めします
私
がやったことで、とてもうまくいきまし
た
わかりました
落ち着いた犬 あなたは私に
日本語を学び続けるように促しました 良い仕事を続けて
ください スーパーチャットをありがとうございました
そして
、あなたの将来の研究を頑張ってください アントワーヌバンド
これを大きくすることはできませんが
、スーパーチャットに感謝します すごい 20
ドル 非常に感謝しています どうもありがとう
バンダ ベン・バンデル ユーチューバー
ええと、デジタルトロフィーです ありがとう
Angry Men
でも日本語
版です 12 Angry Men の日本語版のようなもの
ですが、もう少しコメディーなので、
ええと、
わかりました。 日本の映画の日本語字幕を見つけるのはとても難しいの
ですが、実際に
DVD を購入したり、Amazon などで映画を購入したり、
iTunes などの
ように知っている場合は、通常バンドレイがあれば
大丈夫だと思います。
ええと、スーパー チャットえ
えと
、12 人の怒っている男性よりも少しコメディーなタッチがあります。
これは、法廷ドラマのようなものです。これは、
法廷ドラマのスラッシュ コメディのようなものです。
ええと、
外国の
サイバーパンク エッジです。 ランナー
外国
人 外国人
これは本当に物議を醸すことかもしれませんが、
カウボーイビバップ
のオリジナルシリーズ
と
サイバーパンクのエッジランナーの両方を見たチャットの
人々にとって、これについては本当に興味があります。
ええと、個人的には、個人的
にはサイバーパンクの方が好きだと思います。
ええと、とにかく、
ええと
、日本の人々とコンバース会話を練習するとき
、彼らが会話したくない、
または会話しようとすることに不快であることを示すために拾う記号スラッシュのボディランゲージはありますか?
たくさんありますが、もし
あなたは
、私が説明するのは不可能だろうとさえ思わないほど多くあります。私が言いたいの
は、それは
日本語の
ようなものです。言語全体のようなものです。
誰かが
何もしない
ようなちょっとした会話 彼らが話している人を称賛するか、そうそう
、私はあなたに贈り物
をもらい
ました しかし、私が見た
私はあなたがそれが好きかもしれないと思ったのを知っています 私はあなたがそれを好きかもしれないと思っていました あなたはそれを大したことでは
ないことを知っています
か？ プレを手に入れた あなたに送られてきました
が、あなたは日本語で物事を行う必要があり、もっと回りくどい方法で行う必要があります。それは、日本語のボディランゲージ
のようなものにも当てはまり
ます。
ええと
、地面をよく見たり、時計をチェックしたりするのが好きかもしれません。
たくさん、または彼らの電話で、あなた
はもちろん本当に明白なことのように知っています
が、ええと
、数え切れないほどたくさんあります。
なぜこれら2つのLMAOを比較するのですか?
私はキャンセルしました
が
、多くの人がカウボーイビバップを絶対に愛しています.
カウボーイビバップ
はアニメのランドマーク
だ
と思います. それはシリーズにまったく影響を与えなかったでしょう
し
、私は
すべてのエピソードがストーリーに影響を与えるシリーズのファンです.
私は一つのことのように
サイバー パンク エッジ ランナーズが本当に大好きです。
すべての
エピソードがストーリーを進行させているように感じました。
また、音楽に関してもそう思います。
雰囲気のキャラクターの対話アクション
シーケンスは
いたるところにあります。ええと、カウボーイ ビバップは確かに
傑作ですが、私は一度も行ったことがありません。
人々が
話しているのを本当に聞いた.多分それ
はシリーズに対する私の認識かもしれないが、彼らは
また2つ、3つ、あるいは4つのようなものだ.
おそらくそのシリーズのそのエピソードよりも多く、
これは実際にはそうではないと感じた. ストーリーを進めていて、
カウボーイビバップを見て
いて、特にいくつかのエピソードがありまし
た。特に初期のエピソードで
は、主人公が一緒に教会にいて
、彼は銃撃戦をしていて、フェイは
あなたです. 教会の柱の 1 つのように縛られていることを知っているし、
彼
が窓からノックアウトされている
ようで
、その時点までのシリーズのように全体が好きだ.
絶対に魅了されました 私はこれが
信じられないほど素晴らしいアニメのように信じられないほど
良いアニメだと思っていました 人々がなぜそんなに夢中になっているのか完全に理解でき
ますが、その後も
続き、何かを待っているようなエピソードが3つか4つあり
ました
ストーリーで起こるのは新しいことですが、彼ら
はどこかに行って、バックストーリーのようなメインキャラクターや将来の彼らの目的などに
実際には関係のないことをし
たいとは思わないでしょう。
いつになったら本題に戻るんだろうと思って待っていたような気が
しました。その意味
では、どちらも一種のセットであり
、カウボーイビバップが本当にサイバーパンクに似ているかどうかはわかりません。
それはあなたです. いわば
SFアドベンチャーを知らないのと同じようにもっと知っ
ていますが、
ええと、コンボイが進化すると誰も考えていないので
、この意見のためにキャンセルされると思うのは私だけですか?
すみません スーパーチャットをさせてください
オーケー ダグ
マイルストーンおめでとう 当然の
ことです 数学や科学などの日本語の知識を深めるために探していました
オンラインで利用できるリソースは何か スラッシュ
海外で利用できる あなたは大きな
インスピレーションを与えてくれました
ええと、日本に来て
数学や科学のような日本語の教科の知識を深める
ために正直に言うと
、小学校の教科書のように取得する
か
、中学校の
数学や科学の教科書のようにレベルが高いか、実際にはええとYouTubeのように
ええと、彼は本当にクールなビデオを持って
います ええとについて話している本当に良いビデオ 彼が話している名前を思い出せません 彼が話している名前は思い出せません
数学の定理の
ようなもので、300年ほど解決されていなかったようなものです
ええと、最近では
20年ほど前のように または、30年ぶりに
数学者がい
て、ついにそれを解決し、彼は
その全話を日本語で
話しました。それは本当に興味深いです。
彼は時々
、彼は YouTuber に関連するトピックを取り上げます。
私の意見では、本当に優れた YouTuber であり、
暗号通貨を知らない
、メタバースを知っている、
解釈できることを知っているなどのトピックを分解するのに役立ちます。
そこ
では、ブロックチェーンのような科学分野にいると主張することができ、
有名な数学者のように彼が時々再び話すそのようなことについて
、そしてええと、それはあなたにとって良い方法かもしれません。
もう一度勉強してください
YouTube
はありません 映画の日本語はかなり自然ではありません
アニメほど誇張されていませんが
、英語では基本的に同じ
です 前に私が推薦した映画について話しているのであれば、それは
非常に自然な日本語です そうではありません
アニメのように誇張されている
ので、これ
がカウボーイ
ビバップの話だと思う
人
はいますか？ ええと、正しいビバップは
スタートレックやバスターのようなアンソロジーです
ええと、スクラッグス
ええ、この意味で
カウボーイビバップを見る正しい方法は、
スタートレックのようなものに似
ているということです。
非常に興味深い裏話と
、彼らが時々行っているさまざまな冒険を知っているようなもの
であり、それ
から
、同様に起こる根底にある物語のよう
な
ものもあります.
カウボーイ
ビバップについてちょっと気になったのですが
、新しい仕事か何かを
見つけた場所に行って、このこと
をしてから戻ってきて
そのエピソードで起こったすべてのこと
は、そのエピソードで
それ自体で完了した
ようであり、以前に何が起こったの
か、後で何が起こるのかは関係ありませんでした。 全体的な
ストーリーであり
、その意味でも、私は個人的に
少しダウンタイムがあったように感じ
ました.次の大きな
インポートを待っていました.必ずしも大きなことではありませんが
、ナレーションが進行するのを待っていました.それが私が
シリーズを本当に愛している理由です.
あなたが知っているように、エッジランナーや
モンスター、または別の良いもの
だと思いますキョージンは本当に良い例だと思います。
すべてのエピソード
がストーリーを進行させ
、ええと、寒いエピソードの場所がありますが、ええと、武士はそれらの1つです
個人的には、
眠る前にリラックス
するのが好きです そうですね 繰り返しになりますが、それでも
本当に楽しかった
と思います 個人的に
は、あの 2 つか 3 つのエピソードが好きだったら、もう少し楽しかったと思います
4つのよう
に、確かではありませんが、いくつかありました
.それらはすべて異なる民話であるため、すべてエピソードです.
ええ、それはそれを見る一つの方法だと
思います.
では、またキャンセルされる前に、次のトピックに移りましょう。では、
続けましょう。では
、これが何であったかということですね。
カウボーイ ビバップはサイバーでもなく、近未来でもありません。
ホームステイ先をどのように見つけましたか
東京 大学でやりました
ええと サイバーパンクは関連ジャンル ええと
燃え尽きる
若者 知りませんでした それが
トロープではなくジャンルのテーマのようなものだとは知りませんでした
ええと
ドーガンは私のお気に入りのフレッシュ トルーパーです
オーケー トーマス ワオ
まあ、100ドルはクレイジーです。
ローガンさん、500kおめでとうござい
ます。文字通り何年もの間、あなたのチャンネルとパトロンに登録されて
いるなんて信じられません。トーマスのキャラクターでもっとビデオを作り続けてください。
声をかけられた気持ち ありがとう ああ、あなたが話して
いるビデオを作ったときは面白かった
です
R.I.P 交換留学生のトーマス それ
についての面白いことは、スクリプトを書いている
ときにそのビデオを作ったときに気づいた
ことです th 私はそのダイナミクスを探求したことはあり
ません 私は定期
的に日本人と外国人との間で会話
をしています。
日本の会社とか、
友達同士で
家族旅行とかで一緒に遊んでる
みたいだけど、留学中の学生を舞台にした動画は作ったことがなかったような気が
します。 ホームステイの家族
と二人は、留学生のせいであまり会話が出来ないのが好きで
、彼の日本語が下手だった
ので、
まともなビデオを知ってもらえると思ったのです
が、私は作り続けます.
もっとスーパーチャットに
感謝します。また、
何年にもわたるパトレオンでのサポートにも感謝します。また、カストラ
イエス 100 ドル ああ、私の神よ
、アカスパ
で、自分のセン ドリーム キックを打ち負かしてください。
もう
クレイジーです。ありがとう
ドーガンさんには本当に感謝しています。ドーガンさんは
まだ日本語のレッスンを行っています
か。ええと、それについて話す良い機会かもしれませんが、
私
が日本語を教えていることを知らない人のために、ほとんどの人はこれを知っていると思います
が、私は日本語を教えています。
私のpatreonの発音とピッチアクセント
今すぐチャットにリンクを残し
ます ええと、ええと
、教室では教えられていない日本語の要素がたくさんあると私は
強く信じています。
それらを研究することで、
間違いなく悪い習慣を身につけることができ、それは修正するのが
非常に非常に困難
であり、
発音にとっては必ずしも
大したことではないと思いますが、ピッチアクセントは通常教えられないため、ピッチアクセントにとっては大したことだと思います
教室で
高低アクセントを少しでも学べ
ば、日本語に非常に大きな違いが
生まれると思うので、ビデオ形式でパトレオンに再び日本語の高低アクセントを教え
ています。
分解された re シリーズ
日本語の高低アクセントのすべての概念
をわかりやすい英語で分解します。
少なくとも圧倒的多数の
レッスンで
は、NHK アカデミーに通った誰かからの高品質のネイティブ日本語の録音を使用
しています。 ネイティブの録音で
まだ更新されていないレッスンを更新し続けてい
ます.すべてを数えると、シリーズの合計で85または何かのようなレッスンがあるのではないか
と思います.
まだ更新されていない 20 ほどのような
ものですが、それらはすべてはるかに
高度なトピックです。繰り返しになりますが
、できるだけ自然に聞こえたい場合は、
個人的
に私の patreon シリーズにサインアップすることをお勧めします。
日本の給料について学ぶことはたくさんあり
ますが、これまで勉強したことがない場合は、
もう 1 つお知らせしたいと
思います
比較的近い将来、
1 か月以内にプライベート ピッチ アクセント レッスンを開始する予定です。私たちは
ネイティブ
を見つけました。
また、トレーニングを受けて
おり、日本の元ニュース キャスターだったネイティブ スピーカーを見つけました。彼女は連絡を取りました。
そして、私は高低アクセントを教えようとしていると言いました.
マンツーマンレッスンをしたい生徒と私をつなぐ何かを一緒にやってみてください
。近い将来、私たちは物事を正しく設定します. 今
、彼女は
マンツーマンのレッスンを
行う予定です。将来的に
は、シリーズを経験した人
やシリーズを経験している
が、直接的なフィードバックが必要な人のために、グループレッスンも行う予定です。
なぜなら、 ビデオ
シリーズなので、
自分のペースで見て、概念を学び
、リスニングドリルが好きで、
シャドーイングなどを行いますが、
ええと、私はすべての日本語を個人的に批判していません.
いる人
私のコースなので、コース
自体は非常に安く
、月額10ドル程度なので非常に
手頃な価格
ですが、個人的なフィードバックが必要な人のため
に、近い
うちにそれを提供する予定です。
もしあなたがそれにアクセスできる最初の人の一人になりたいのなら、もう一度patreonにサインアップすることをお勧めします。興味の
ある人のため
に
もう一度リンクをここに残します。
それは
恥知らずなプラグです わかりました オーケストラ 再び
あなたの優れた教えを邪魔しない
ようにします でも音楽のクジラの群れを何と呼びます
か わかりません これはある種の
冗談で 今私の頭の上を飛んでいるようなもの
です それはポッド
です 時間通りに ええと
ドイツ語であなたに電話させました
ええと、私はそれを作りました
ええと、彼はオーケストラまたはカストラと言いました
ええと、ジョークがあり
ます 申し訳ありません
大丈夫 NHKといえば ニュースから日本語を学ぶ
NHKワールドでの優れたショートショー 丁寧なNHK日本語を聞いて
ええとLMAO 答えは一目瞭然です
ええと
仕事 ストロー
それは
ラフです
が、感謝します
うーん
シャチのクジラは正しいです オルカは
クジラの鍋を何と呼びますか
オークのストロー
はそれを
釘付けにしました
申し訳ありません
私は英語の理解力が少し遅れています 私は少し
遅いので大丈夫
YouTubeチャンネルのように聞こえるゲームセラピー クールなドーガン 漢字にどのように
アプローチしますか
私はこれまで何年にもわたって約100の漢字を学びました
しかし、私には正しいアプローチが欠けている
誰もが座ってそれを書き続けると言っている
だから実際には基本的
にそれを持っている ええと、私はそうではありません ええと
、もっと良いアプローチがあると
思います。より良いアプローチは、単に Anki を使用することだと思います
SRSアプリのよう
なアプリ
は、漢字を覚えるのではなく、個々の漢字ではなく単語を覚えるために使用するこれらのフラッシュカードアプリのよう
なものですチャットで単語を入力します
今サイコこれ sは、PSYを覚えるアプリのように使用
するのではなく、日本語で最高のように最高を意味し、
後で
コールの単語または漢字
を覚えてから、さまざまな読み方をすべて覚えます.
個人的には
、個々の単語を覚えるのが最善だと思います.
言葉のサイクルを覚えて
、たくさんの言葉を学ぶと、
ゆっくりと、しかし確実に
、浸透を通じて漢字のさまざまな読み方も学ぶ
ようになるので、その
意味で、より多くのことを得ることができると思います。
単語と漢字
を暗記しようとしている場合
は、2 つの時間を分割する
必要がありますが、単語だけを暗記する場合は、漢字を暗記する必要があります。
少し遅くなりますが、
続ければ覚えられる
と同時に、より多くの単語を学ぶことができます。
通常、日本語の勉強を始めたばかりの場合は、それが
より良い方法です
が、私はこれまでに一度もありませ
ん 座って
漢字を何度も書く
アプローチが好きだったし、菌学は
その意味でそれほど良いとは思わない. 漢字がたくさんあるように.
基本的
に私が知っている誰よりも、彼は私がしたのとまったく同じアプローチをとった.
彼は私が
したのと同じこと
をした.
浸透を通して漢字を
覚えるでしょう
が、漢字については、
ほとんどの日本人のように、最近の日本社会で実際に漢字を書く機会が非常に少ないため、書き方を学ぶのも時間の無駄です.
基本的な日本語の漢字を書くためにさえ、人々はスマートフォン
を取り出さなければならないので、10 分の 9 の
確率で、あなたは読めるだけで
大​​丈夫ですねえ、どうしたソラソラ トロールの大
ファン私は日本語を学び始めました be
少し前にあなたのチャンネルに会ったからです.
素晴らしい仕事の犬と先生の
ソラを続けてください.どうもありがとう
ございました. フロイドのように
フロイド 5月のメリウェザー 5月の天気
メイウェザー その全体的な
状況は本当に面白いよくできたビデオ
でした 私はそれが本当に好きで、
ここでそれについて話すことができるかどうかわかりませんが、ええと、ソラと
私はいくつかのことをしました
彼
が私と同じことを
好きで、反対のことをしていることを知らない人のために、私たちは将来また何かをするつもりです.
Japanese and Sora
は、通常は英語でコメディ コンテンツを作成する日本人の男です
が、彼
は時々日本語を使用することもあります。
同じように、
英語と私のスキットのいくつかを混ぜ合わせるのと
同じように、本当に素晴らしいチャンネルです
良い荒らし
とええ、
私たちはいつかコラボするつもりです ええと、あなたの本当のあなたは誰です
かあなたのビデオの苦いドーガンまたはストリームの素敵な
ドーガンええと、
これは本当の私ですが、
ええと
、本当の私は私が
知らないように非常に興味深いとは思いません
男か何かのようですが、ほとんどの人と同じように、
ええと、書く
ことで、実際に興味深いものを作成できる
と
思います[音楽]ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 最近ホビットのこと
を考えていたの
ですが、混乱しているかもしれません
が、皆さん、
2分ほどで行かなければならないので、
誰か質問や最後に言いたいことが
あれば、私はあなたをお勧めします.
これが最後のチャンスです
ええと
外国
[音楽] すでに学んだ日本語
を修正する特定の方法をお勧めしますか
すでに学んだ日本語を修正
し
てください
ええ、教えません rsは私たちのアクセントのコンテンツを修正できます
外国人
私は行かなければなりませんが、ええと
、あなたの好きな日本の作家と
彼の本は何ですか私の好きな日本の作家は
彼女で、私のお気に入りの彼女の本
は短編小説のコレクションですオーケー
みんな私は行かなければなりませんがありがとう
ストリームにとって、これは信じられないほど素晴らしいもの
でした。ついに
500k に達したなんて信じられないので、十分に時間がかかりました。長年にわたる
すべて
のサポートに感謝します。
近い将来
、チャンネルでいくつかのアナウンスがあります。
一部の人が楽しんでくれることを願ってい
ますので、私は行かなければなり
ませんが、長年にわたるサポートに感謝します
。またすぐにお会いしましょう。
みんなまた後でね